welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down one of the biggest
mysteries in Westworld season 3 that is
who is in Charlotte Hales body
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the best fan theories and the
evidence to support them there's a ton
of people that the character could be
but we think we've narrowed it down to a
select few that really feel like they
could be the one driving the ship though
these are all theories at the moment we
will be discussing some of the major
plot points in season 3 so far so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
show yet then I highly recommend that
you turn off now don't forget to
subscribe to the channel as we do
breakdowns on Westworld every week and
with that out the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of who is in Charlotte Hales
body okay so up top we're just going to
be telling you the choices so you know
who will be covering as they get weirder
and weirder the obvious ones are teddy
Clementine the man in black Abernathy
and Angela but the more obscure theories
are that it could be the twisted
personality of Dolores aka Wyatt and
Caleb himself I know that last one
sounds crazy but as we get further into
the video you'll see there's actually a
ton of evidence for him whoever is in
the host is clearly having an identity
crisis and we know that they destroyed
the body that they were initially in
when Dolores left the park she had an
intact copy of Hale however as we saw
what they needed to rebuild the shell in
the opening of episode 3 so we can
assume that this is because it was torn
apart Hale is clearly going through this
again another is lip service to the real
Hale wanting to break free I do believe
that this may be the Machine version of
schizophrenia so yes a eyes can have
mental health issues to the one host
that we know that it isn't is Bernard as
though he was taken out of the park with
Dolores he was shown to Hale in episode
3 so we can pretty much rule him out as
being an accomplice unless unless they
did this to throw us off the scent
anyway I don't want to get into that now
firstly is Teddy this is probably the
most obvious choice out of every
character but just because he's the
go-to it doesn't mean that he should be
ruled out Dolores and whoever is
masquerading as Hale
clearly know each other very well they
share very intimate moments with one
another in which they discuss their past
and shared history and thus it's a safe
bet to assume that the host has a
connection to Dolores much in the same
way that Teddy did Teddy apparently went
to hosts heaven in season two after
shooting himself but that doesn't mean
he can't return obviously james marsden
has been asked several times whether he
would be coming back to the show and
when speaking to comicbook.com he stated
I mean I'm not allowed to say anything
but I would say that just based on your
hypothesis if he's died four thousand
times then I would say that the odds are
probably strong yeah and you know but
it's a question I can't answer and I
think time will tell
so mazdan is hinting that he may return
and what better way to do it than
through an enigmatic new form the new
Hale clearly knows that the old Hale is
the face of the enemy which is knowledge
that Teddy would have so this does make
a ton of sense however as mentioned it
does just seem too on the nose for me
and for a show that prides itself on
having twists I can't see Teddy being
the one inside the next choice that I
don't think is the case is the man in
black though never out and out confirmed
as a host the post-credits scene of
season two did indeed hint that
something was up with the character
after apparently killing his daughter
during the season the man in black
finally reached the door which was the
destination I had been searching for for
what seemed like a lifetime upon getting
there he arrived at the forge to find it
completely in ruins here he was greeted
by the daughter that he'd shot and
killed in the prior entry he believed
that he was in a simulation but his
daughter Emily stated that he wasn't
instead she said that he was in their
world or what was left of it she told
him that he had reached their
destination under similar circumstances
before and that they were actually just
establishing a baseline in order to
verify fidelity this of course happened
with James Dallas earlier in season two
and it did him that William had died
long ago and this resurrection of the
character had been created in order to
provide somewhat immortality for him so
it does appear that he is indeed
synthetic and though this could be
inhale I believe that there's a
different purpose for him in the show
Nolan and Lisa join interviews stated
that will
was far ahead in the future when the
world is incredibly decayed and I think
he will show why humans may have taken
other measures to ensure their survival
Westworld season one and two dealt with
timelines and the differences between
them whereas I think season 3 will deal
with different worlds and we will have a
real one in a simulation created by
Obama I believe that William will be in
this real world and this is why in the
previews we see him in several shared
locations if this is the truth and there
are indeed two different worlds
then he can't be in hail and she's part
of the pristine simulation that makes
the world look like a utopia now before
you jump down my throat for seeing that
there's two different worlds just look
at the poster for Westworld season three
we can see a desert landscape with a
destroyed city in the background which
we know isn't the case in this season so
I do believe that there is two different
realities all going on at once anyway
this isn't the video for that theory but
yeah I just thought I'd put that in
there to provide a bit more evidence
next up is Angela we know that she's one
of the oldest house in the park as she
first created William as a young man and
has appeared throughout several of the
time jumps Angela's prime directive was
to seduce and the first time Hale comes
face to face with her ex-husband she
instantly moves to kiss him she is also
a devoted follower of one of our other
choices Wyatt so she could easily fit
into the role of someone that is willing
to kill for Dolores a host that shared
elements of his personality where this
theory falls down is that Angela blew
herself up in season two but there is
definitely a possibility here for her to
be inside Hale Clementine is another
similar choice to Angela in many ways
Clem has always been a wild card within
the show and as season 1 progressed she
brought forward the darker side of a
personality Clem was also a loyal
follower of Wyatt and she eventually
helped to lead the house to the valley
beyond in season two this is why I don't
think she's behind Hale as it just seems
like she's served her purpose and
fulfill the rock and being one of the
more likely candidates I can now see her
being unlikely to be in the body for
that exact reason a following contender
is Peter Abernathy aka Dolores his
father
Abernathy went on a pretty wild ride
throughout the two seasons and the
sympathetic character really exemplified
the police of
now why this is possible is because of
my first video covering the season I had
several comments stating that Abernathy
was listed as Hales name and closed
captions for the trailer now I have
rewatched the trailers with closed
captions on however it looks like they
were either not there or this has since
been removed I don't know but the
character is not listed as Abernathy
when speaking but the other characters
such as Delores Maeve and Caleb all do
have their names before they talk so
this could have been removed and it does
make sense that Delores would want to
keep a father close I do believe that if
this was the case that it may have
hinted towards another theory and that
is Wyatt now before we get into that I
just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the Star Wars
Skywalker Saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
when the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the theories in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of April
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize it's the
best of luck that everyone who takes
part okay so if Abernathy you was indeed
in the closed captions and it could
highlight that Delores is in fact
connected to Hale in several ways the
lorises surname is of course also
Abernathy so this draws a connection
here in season 1 we learned that Delores
had a darker side to her code known as
Wyatt a homicidal murderer that had went
on a massacre in one of the earliest
storylines Delores slowly unearthed this
and it brought out the worst side of a
personality so it makes sense that she
would try to remove this however it
would still have its uses
Delores knows this personality very well
and she also knows that should it come
down to it it can defend itself there's
a lot of lip service and hints towards
this such as Delores saying that neither
her or whoever Hale is have a mother or
father
she also states that she trusts her more
than anyone else and that no one knows
you like me and no one knows me like you
in addition to this at one point in the
episode Dolores states to Hale you
belong to me which could indicate that
she does indeed come from her own code
when Hale murders a man later on in
episode 3 Hill says I remember what it's
like to be me which speaks to the more
homicidal nature within Dolores when the
two meet at one point
episode three dolores tries to reassure
her that she's okay and they both get
into bed and go to the fetal position
this could symbolize that they have a
shared birth and were created together
on top of this it also resembles the yin
and yang symbol i want to shout our gary
lee fowler for noticing this and even
the color scheme resembles the pattern
incredibly close this brings the idea of
both sides of the personality Dolores
and Wyatt balancing out one another and
being part of the same whole therefore
with all of this iconography it does
seem likely that Hale may indeed be
Wyatt the darker side of Dolores and
finally the theory that I'm also seeing
pick up a lot of steam is that the host
is Caleb shoutouts to liz P for dropping
this on my previous Westworld video and
pretty much inspiring me to make this
entire breakdown after thinking about it
for a while I think it becomes more and
more likely the further we look into it
firstly we know that Caleb's mother
dealt heavily with schizophrenia to the
point that she even abandoned her own
child this could become hereditary and
therefore Caleb would deal with the
identity crisis
far worse than others we know that some
hosts have swapped bodies without any
problem but Caleb knowing that his
mother had a mental illness that
revolved around this could create
paranoia and make him distrust what he's
seeing secondly Caleb's mother does not
recognize him and this exchange of her
not knowing who he is is similar to the
one that the fake Hale has with Hales
real son Nathan caleb is depressed in
real life and we know this from the fact
that he was receiving therapy from a
machine that mimicked the voice of his
deceased friend he also has suicidal
tendencies which are indicated by his
future path which is revealed at the end
of episode 3 this could be why Hale is
obsessed with self harming now how he
could be transferred is because many
people including myself believe that
Caleb may in fact be a synth right now I
think that the world we are
predominantly seeing is a simulation
within Rehoboam Dolores has infiltrated
this in order to gain soldiers and this
is why we never see Caleb interacting
with other hosts just Dolores the
majority of them are still out in the
real world and this is actually taking
place before Dolores returns there to
start a war I think that the Caleb we
saw killing himself is what happened to
the
caleb and he was then placed into the
simulation which turned the clock back I
believe its able to predict things so
accurately because they've already
happened
whether Dolores entering this world has
caused there to be an anomaly the events
we are seeing with Hale are in the real
world after Dolores has recruited him
and this is why he's finding it
difficult to fit in not only is he
having an existential crisis but he's
also dealing with this new body and thus
he's struggling mentally there are hints
to Kayla being synthetic due to the fact
that we see him waking up which mimics
the look of Dolores waking up in season
one there are a lot of similarities with
other hosts he also lives in an almost
Grand Theft Auto like world which could
be a synthetic via creation for players
to enter we know he's being shot in the
head before and somehow survived it and
yeah there's a lot of things going on
the more and more I think about it the
more and more likely it becomes from
Shia West world still has a lot of
curveball to throw our way now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on who
you think Hale is so if you have an even
better suggestion then make sure you
leave it below if you enjoyed this video
then please drop a thumbs up as it
massively helps the channel out and make
sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 3 which is going to be linked at
the end we've gone over the entire
season week by week so definitely make
sure you stay a lock to the channel for
all of the developments on the show as
it drops you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come check just
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]